Voiceover: So in the
last couple of videos,
we've talked about Benjamin Franklin
as a printer, we've talked about him as a
successful public leader, as a successful
businessman, but we also
know Benjamin Franklin,
and we've talked about him
as a successful writer,
with Poor Richard's
Almanac, but there's this
other side of Benjamin
Franklin which kind of
makes him larger than
life, which he was also
a significant scientist.
Voiceover: Yes, you know,
he would have thought
it was strange that you could aspire to be
a great citizen and
not care about science.
Back then, you should know about science.
So he did everything from tried to track
the gulf stream, he
discovered ways to use dark
fabrics to absorb heat,
he creates the great
Franklin stove, a fireplace
that's a wonderful
way to be more efficient
in terms of heating
a room without getting
it all smoky, and...
Voiceover: And also not wasting the heat
I think, normally in a
fireplace all the heat
goes straight up, and out.
Voiceover: Right, and it
sort of had a nice little
top to it, a little plate,
that got very hot, and so
he was a very practical inventor.
Even things like bifocals,
he's riding along
the road one day, and he keeps wanting to
read, but then look up
into the distance, and
he says, "Well, why
don't I have two pieces
"of glass melded together, one that's good
"for reading, and one
that's good for looking
out in the distance."
So, it wasn't like he
was a research scientist,
he was just a practical inventor.
What makes him into a
great research scientist
is when finally, in the
1740s and early 1750s,
he starts doing the
electricity experiments.
Voiceover: And this is
important, this is actually
something I learned
when I read your book on
Benjamin Franklin, is that,
I mean this was real, as you mentioned,
this was real research.
This was something that, understanding the
nature of elecricity,
the nature of lightning,
and how to manipulate it.
Voiceover: Yeah, we think
of him as a doddering old
dude flying a kite in
the rain, but in fact,
those electricity
experiments were the most
important experiments of that era.
Not only for the practical use of them,
but for the theory.
Up until then, people had
created static electricity,
you know, when you rub
your sweater against a
piece of glass, and lots of
sparks come out, and they
thought that electricity
was two different fluids,
and they had two different
names for the fluids.
Franklin realizes it's
a single fluid, and he
creates the idea of positive and negative,
plus and minus, those
type of things, so that
it's a flow of electricity,
and he does that
with his electricity
experiments that really begin
in the 1740s, partly as
a parlor trick, 'cause
he loves it, but then he
realizes, no, let's study
this stuff - electricity.
Voiceover: And it was a
real issue, I mean people
were dying because of lightning.
I remember in the book,
there was a particularly
funny, I forgot the exact
quote, where he said,
"Churches get to be, tend to be hit
"disproportionately, so it seems like God
"is not favoring them." (laughing)
Voiceover: Right, well you
know what they used to do,
was they would sanctify
the church bells, so that
it would ward off the
lightning, and they would
even sometimes store gunpowder inside
churches with sanctified bells.
But the lightning kept
hitting the steeples of the
churches, and people in
Germany, Italy, and then
the United States, there
were these huge explosions,
lightning was the great
scourge of the times.
Voiceover: So to ward off lightning,
they would sanctify a metal bell,
and put it at the top of the tower.
Voiceover: Bingo! (laughing)
It did not work!
And Franklin has a wonderful
line in one of his letters
which is, "You'd think
we would try something
different, and see if
that worked." (chuckling)
And so Franklin looks at
sparks, that he's been
looking at from his
electricity experiments,
and he's been creating these little sparks
with the static
electricity, but then using
wire to make it into
a flow of electricity,
and put it into a battery.
He gives us the name "battery" 'cause he
puts it together a lot of Leyden jars,
which is the way they
used to store electricity.
And so he's looking at
the similarity between
sparks and lightning.
And in his notebook, he
makes a little chart.
He said, well sparks have these qualities,
they're fast, they jump,
there's a sulfurous
smell, they make a little
crack, and lightning
has the same qualities.
And he does a wonderful
notation at the bottom
of that notebook page,
very scientist-like,
he says, "Let the experiments be made."
And that's how you get
the lightning experiments.
Voiceover: He literally,
it's a little bit of a
legend now, but he
literally did go out into
a rainstorm and tie a
kite with a silk thread,
to a kind of a key
attached to a Leyden jar?
Voiceover: Well, what he did was as clouds
were passing over, he and his son William
went out into a field,
and as the rain started,
they flew the kite, and
they tried to draw the
electricity down from
the clouds, 'cause it was
his theory that a
lightning strike was just
a spark coming out of a cloud.
And at first it didn't
work, but as the cloud got
nearer, he could see
the little fibers on the
silk get raised, and
there was a key at the end
of it, and that's where the electricity,
the charge collected, and then he was able
to put it into a Leyden jar, or a battery.
Voiceover: So really what
he was doing, is he was
connecting, because the
clouds are getting a,
they're kind of at a different electric
potential up here, by
kind of connecting it
with his conducting
silk thread that's wet,
he was able kind of to get the Leyden jar
to save potential.
It wasn't like the lightning
struck like Back to the Future.
Voiceover: No, it wasn't like
lightning striking him,
he was drawing some
of the charge down from
the cloud, but that
showed him that what
lightning was, was a discharge
from the cloud of its electric potential.
Voiceover: Right, and that's significant,
'cause when he figured
that out, that you could
manipulate electric, that
lighting was electricity,
that he could kind of
solve the church problem.
Voiceover: The big, big
problem, and you look at that
kite you've drawn, what
does that show you?
It says, I get it, if we put
something up there like that,
like a lightning rod,
and he knew that pointed
metal objects were very
good at drawing the flow
of electricity, so he
said, why don't we put up
a lightning rod, and he
described exactly how to do it.
They ended up testing it
in France, first, 'cause he
published the lightning
rod way of doing it,
but later on he replicates the experiments
in the United States,
and it makes him the most
famous person probably, other than maybe
the King of France, and
the King of England,
the most famous person
in the world because
he has solved this
astonishingly big problem
of how do we ward off lightning from
striking our building.
Voiceover: Especially tall buildings like
church and castle towers, and this is
where he saves lives, this is a...
Voiceover: Oh saves hundreds of lives,
by far the most important
invention of the time,
and of course, we still
use lightning rods,
we still ground, have
grounded points on top
of buildings to make sure...
Voiceover: It's a very
simple idea, that you give
kind of this pointed conductor point,
that's really high up,
the lightning will want
to strike that, and then
you construct a path
for the lightning, so
it can go to the ground,
and not have to go through the building.
Voiceover: And what he does in his house
in Philadelphia, especially
'cause he's about to go
to England again at the time, he puts up
a lightning rod, he
grounds it, but he puts
a tiny little bell, so
that when the electricity's
coming down from the storm is approaching,
and it's drawing the electrical charge
from the clouds, a tiny
little bell will sort of
bounce back and forth, being jolted by the
charges coming there, and
it drove Deborah Read,
his wife, absolutely to distraction,
so there's a wonderful
letter he writes home
from England, telling her how to dismantle
the bell, and it will still be safe.
Voiceover: Fascinating.